what is up everybody i'm adam ak here
for anime outpour back again another
week over rant cafe episode 45 this time
joining me we got anime reconyx taco and
soul maka and in this episode we're
gonna be discussing the age-old question
our anime fans desperate virgin losers
nuts to you this is an important
question and my opinion is the opposite
of recons so i think you should start I
wanna start Oh is your because because
it's gonna my opinions gonna be the
opposite of yours so I did not say that
Oh although you said that no call me out
first now you guys know why I wanted to
do this topic because it's gonna be
hilarious absolutely hilarious but yeah
so basically to give you guys some
context ya guy that I never heard of
before but apparently he is a champion
kickboxer I have the link to his tweet
in the description by the way if you
want to check it out but he said a few
days ago if you are over 15 like and
like cartoons you are a loser anime
Dragon Ball Z etc no excuse plus any
woman loses respect for you grow up and
this and this generated a bunch of
controversy like out on Twitter with
people on addressing this tweet for
never world made a response video to
this chick or you made a response video
to this and a bunch of other smaller
youtubers so it's generated a lot of
controversy and I wanted to talk about
you know what why does he say this is
their truth and what he says and also
why do we react in such a you know angry
way when something like this happens why
don't we just be like oh [ __ ] that I got
how many we know who he is why do we get
so upset so I wanted to kind of talk
about this with all of you well the fact
that there is such a reaction means that
someone was offended and
means there is some truth behind it at
least to some people probably means that
people over 15 means like grown-ups who
watch cartoons or losers yes he does but
why exactly would he say that I mean if
he brought out
they then controversy because making
controversy gets them gets people more
famous look at double for anime he has
400,000 subscribers yes I do know that
but why would he bring out anime in the
first place which probably proves that
he has washed it before yeah I mean well
he said cartoons and anime in it
cartoons anime like you know like the DC
animated films and stuff like that or
the animated series and stuff so you
know yeah no not just now but then like
he posted on on Twitter like yeah I
slept with your waifu so he was posting
pictures of anime girls and pictures of
a real-life girl who was similar to the
anime girl and just yeah he was like I
slept with your wife or you jealous
I was like what what is this guy doing I
have no idea well in his defense the
reason why he was posting those pictures
are because he opened up his messages
and allowed people to private message
him and whoever actually goes to this
guy and sends him a picture saying look
how hot this anime girl is okay there's
absolutely no logical reason why anyone
would say that to this person and what
I'm thinking is that this guy is just
messing around he's just kind of like a
troll and he's just trying to trigger
people and anime community is
particularly sensitive
by the way Kaiser Trigger says he's 27
and watches Chinese cartoons he is a
[ __ ] loser is what he says I don't
know should we should we argue guys or
should we just let kind of trigger have
his news earnest I say let him have it
I mean here's the thing people who are
old let's say Seoul for example he's he
is married he watches animations why old
you are
he said I'm Odin I mean what I mean is I
don't know how old you are so how I was
like lordy yeah okay well so similar
than adult let's take that for examples
all his adult he's married
yes kids and he watches anime and he's a
hentai artist I wouldn't say that is a
virgin loser why would a loser yes
exactly
so obviously this these are all things
that you could put on someone's resume
for like when the Queen of England is
looking for someone tonight
that's basically what she's gonna be
looking for in a perfect world yes a
family man who loves anime manga has a
nearly religious love of manga and is
also a hentai artist I think think
that's pretty dope I saw his tweet oh
this guy he has a verified checkmark on
Twitter so I decided to reach her and
research him on Wikipedia and it came up
he's a heavyweight champion kickboxing I
don't even know I did heavy research
also I looked at the description under
his name people on Twitter actually have
the description things under their name
and is that their professional kickboxer
so that's how I got my information yeah
Bora bong says he's nothing he's just a
lightweight champion so yeah that's true
I think he's up world lightweight
champion he's just like the guy's a
lightweight he's no Chuck Norris he
doesn't even lift yeah he's like he's
like you know he's cut but you know
where's the manifesto I think his main
problem is he's never watched JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure know clearly he hasn't
watched Sao the best anime ever man yeah
we had a long we had a please recon
don't don't
DM this guy and tell him to watch it I
was going
[Music]
and just be like check out Americans now
no look I'm just gonna send him a
picture of asana and tell him what do
you think of this
go watch Sao and tell me what you think
oh yeah just convince him that sa it was
best anime easy as that
well anyway speaking of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure we had a whole of discussion
voice chat on discord and of course if
you're not on our disk or yet link in
the description we chill there all the
time and yeah we were discussing JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure and showing how
bizarre the official art for this show
really is so yeah definitely not
motivated to watch it Knox I'm not look
if you don't want to watch it it's your
loss missing out on this no your
response there that was dope
that was dope I prefer to stick could
kill to kill to be honest well the
firmness of my response I believe it was
that there is official art of sword art
online hentai that's me yeah but the
thing is I personally don't feel
insulted when someone's like Oh anime
fans are losers and virgins because I
know I'm super cool and awesome and
girls love me so I don't feel like you
know threatened by that but there are
people who really do get upset and you
know triggered and the thing is like
whoever made a response video yes but
the thing is that it's like who cares
what some guy thinks why do you you know
why do you get so mad and this is an
interesting issue and I wanted to bring
up the whole PewDiePie thing because we
all know PewDiePie huge anime fan
however whenever he talks about anime he
has to make like self-deprecating jokes
and kind of say that oh yeah I like
anime I'm a loser kind of thing whereas
he can't be like I never
if someone's like what do you you know
do what he like and I say I like anime
or I make youtube videos of what I am I
don't be like oh yeah I know it's so
lame right like I'm like proud of it I
don't think there's anything wrong with
it but PewDiePie and some people do seem
to feel like they should almost be
embarrassed about the fact that they
like anime and I wonder why that is and
then we get you know people like this
kickboxer dude talking I don't really
have to wonder that hard to understand
why PewDiePie would say that on two
levels on one level he has 57 million
subscribers that he needs to impress and
if they're not anime fans and they here
he is then they know the reputation of
anime and that's not so good for him but
if you made jokes in a self-deprecating
way then people start self-deprecating
jokes gets you further on YouTube yeah
my question is why does anime have this
reputation in the first place where you
feel like you need to defend yourself
for liking it or where you know random
do they probably knows nothing about
anime like this kickboxer guy is like
this is for animators bah
what's down you know what why I mean I
mean yeah I get the culture thing like
in Japan in it why it's seen as a button
because in Japan is very work focused
the lifestyle there and it you know
people working six days a week seven
days a week
as standard so if you are not working
yeah if you're watching anime if you've
got time to watch anime or weed manga
then basically means you're not working
you're not contributing to society
you're just like a leech you know in
there in there says like that's the way
they see it yeah
but then over in the West it's
completely different yeah I mean it is
completely different we don't run our
society the same way they do so the
stigma that they have shouldn't exist
with us it just shouldn't there's no
point yeah anyone who doesn't know
something about a community or whatever
they only hear the weirdest crap about
it
and then blow it up to some horrible
monster that's like sort of a fact of
life and yes if someone would be out of
the community and they see oh look it's
you know unhealthy smelly people hugging
body pillows I think of myself a lot of
that that's something that that's you
know should be passed down to the
children yeah true but my point is I as
a rational person I think that of course
there's some people who like animate
were weird of course there is aspects of
the anime community like anime itself
that's we were for example lollies you
guys know my [ __ ] opinion on that I
don't get that at all I don't think it
should be a thing but I always know as a
rational person that is not the only
thing that anime is animes of diverse
genres so you can pick and choose what
to watch what kind of things to do not
every anime fan has a bunch of body
pillows I will no longer be able to say
that I'm one of the people that doesn't
soon because you booked we will see a
body pillow reveal in a special video
but others in that yeah like I think
it's just reasonable to assume that yeah
maybe you know there's certain aspects
of the anime community of anime as a
whole that's questionable or not doesn't
meet society's standards but that's just
one afternoon just like you know looking
at watching a Hollywood movie and
assuming that because you watch one
shitty one that all Hollywood movies are
stupid or Ohio the movies are shitty or
you know we have the internet now it's
not like someone has to actually watch
an anime and be like okay I'll try anime
I wonder what it is oh I opened up kill
a kill this is the worst weirdest thing
ever
well I'm not gonna stick with anime you
wanna listen watch Joe Joe's instead of
killer kills exactly Joe Joe's would
give the same exact reaction like what
the hell am i watching but I don't think
that's the case for anyone who actually
has anything against anime I think
they're on the internet and they see
really weird memes going around and
they're like oh my god and also it's
always easier to be an antagonist ant
antagonize a community for weirdnesses
than to actually defend something yeah
also more fun stairs that more
controversy and gets you more popular
yeah people like being [ __ ] disturbers
people ain't being trolls even people
who are famous like deadmau5 are famous
for also being trolls and they just
enjoy doing it so that's the thing when
you get a bunch of people getting
triggered by this type of stuff they get
exactly what they want they get the
attention to get the you know the
reaction they were looking for so that
on the one hand it definitely reveals
that there is a stupid stigma about
anime and even that I think is
unjustified however it also reveals that
there are a lot of anime fans were very
sensitive about their fan more look it's
irrational sensitive doesn't Trump
irrational for most people some people
probably do feel themselves to be
degenerate virgin losers and feel the
need to tweet hentai pictures to kick
boxer guy ya know but I mean for some
people it might not be that they
degenerate 13 losses it might just be
yeah we lost me they don't know how to
talk you know you were breaking up there
was that yes didn't hear anything can
you hear me now
yes yes okay right so ya know well like
I said some people people it might not
be there like the general version loses
but just simply they're still virgins
although as to the stigma they take as
an attack on them because yes they are
virgins yes a a yes for not liking anime
oh yeah I mean like they don't have to
talk to go wasn't stuff that's a good
point because the guy specifically said
that girls don't find guys like anime
attractive and basically no girl is
gonna be interested in you if you like
anime which of course is still because
there are a lot of female anime fans on
top of the fact that you liking anime
has nothing to do with how much girls
like you some girl doesn't like you just
cuz you like Hannah and then she's an
idiot [ __ ]
right there's plenty of girls in the
world but I think that probably touched
a nerve that aspect where he was like
basically you'll never get any girls if
you like anime and I just want to say
that gorgeous chromatic said that boku
no pico is responsible for this kind of
attitude and I mean yeah frankly he's
right yo you wanna mean it became a meme
and blew up and every big YouTube
channel reacted to it
PewDiePie and I mean as just one tons of
people made reactions to that
you know masterpiece yeah but the thing
is there's way more [ __ ] up
live-action porn out there why do we not
say all porn is degenerate because
there's [ __ ] up porn out there and why
well there's you know there's one anime
porn out there that's ridiculous and
people write well anime in general must
be ridiculous like that's the stupidity
there um
Kizer trigger also said you mentioned
double for anime and double frenemy
getting triggered over to filthy Frank
Naruto thing now I don't I don't even
know if he really got triggered or if
he's just a complete troll he just
pretends to get triggered to get
attention I don't know double for anime
you see what he himself tweets and what
he post I don't really follow his tweets
but the thing is yeah I don't know if
he's a troll or if he's insane like I
did it's one of them too but did he live
up to this though I would love to see a
double for anime triggered response to
this whole situation he's probably gonna
do one to be honest yeah he's probably
get to take his shelf if he has a shirt
on I'm not even watching that response
potentially a weapon in his hand yeah
back when I was in high school I used to
hide the fact that I like anime because
I knew that if I if I if I brought out
the fact that I like anime and all the
stuff to like people and then yeah I
would definitely get bullied so yeah I
didn't do that
until I was like in college and all the
stuff I wasn't really
I was like I like anime and people were
like okay with it but yeah and
highschool tend to like hide it because
you will get bullied for liking
something that people don't like at all
and my brothers my brother he sent me a
go
he sent me in the country today he was
walking in college and he saw a guy
walking with an uchiha vest or jacket or
whatever so he said to me and he says
they're everywhere oh yeah it's true
anime fans are getting more mainstream
it's funny I was at university a year
ago or two years ago and I it was
Halloween but I forgot that it was
Halloween and I just see a chick dressed
up as Annie from attack on Titan in full
like pull an P uniform and everything
and I was like what the [ __ ] is
happening but I was like why why someone
doing a very faithful cosplay of an
attack on Titan character on campus well
yeah like I think anime is getting more
mainstream and as it is the people that
don't get it yet the people are like
[ __ ] enemy and some of the other
understand so I hate on it they're gonna
have any reaction saying you know this
anime [ __ ] is everywhere I have a
resistance to it I don't want to be a
part of it so I'm gonna you know talk
[ __ ] about it I think that's just
something you have to accept matter
swordsman coined a new term for double
for anime troll saying so not insane not
a troll patrol saying kind of a bit of
both and caster for life said that
double four was cool in the 2013's
so that's that's good 2013's you were
four years younger
he wasn't four years better yeah also
the cat gamer says that she is a girl I
don't know you say so but on the
Internet's pretty obvious - my main work
at dinner forty year old male and that's
a recon line right there yeah I don't
know I mean for me I've never seen or
experienced myself people getting
bullied for like in anime in high school
yeah I mean but the thing is no but the
thing is though anime was new when I was
in high school back in the West
yeah no no yeah it was new to the West
was new to us and so maybe it never had
enough time to bring a stigma I guess or
a I don't know an opinion of it cuz it
was new so like that was never really
anyone that I've seen like talked ill of
anime and even with my son now and he's
11 he's got in high school now and still
like he has he he has friends that like
anime and stuff and you know there's
there's no problem so yeah I don't know
maybe something just in America where
people are like that or something but
I've never seen or heard of that
happening in England it happens in
different parts of the world the thing
is that there is especially like let's
say conservative areas you might have
like people work on this anime [ __ ] is
like out of control but also it also
depends on the person cuz if you're like
a confident person you have a bunch of
friends in high school then you can say
all I can away they might tease you
budding I'm like yo who cares kind of
thing however if you're like a person
that maybe isn't so popular in school
and people tease you anyway
then anime might be just like another
thing that they would have to tease you
for so you wouldn't wanna you know
advertise it that much so what I
understand about high schools high
school kids are monsters okay just like
in general and no one wants to be that
punching bag in the class so if anyone
does something that's not the norm
exactly all hell will break loose and
that person will be the target of
everyone just so they aren't a target
themselves yeah exactly so it's kind of
like you're just trying to minimize
anything you could be teased for and
that's why you might want to you know hi
do you like anime because anime is
different still but I think soul also
has a point more and more you know
celebrities are talking about
whether it's rappers whether it's
PewDiePie it's becoming more more
mainstream and then people are kind of
discovering it and it's eventually I
think in a few years not even gonna be
that big a deal and people who are
talking about weird [ __ ] and animating
I'm like yeah this is like a weird
aspect of anime this is not like anime
itself this splendid noir you are in the
chat said somebody just needs to pull me
up for a 24-hour anime channel I think
that's a good idea
I will definitely bring Ram cafe to a 24
hour anime channel I'm ready for that
[ __ ] let's do it what are we gonna do in
there just tell an anime channel program
called ran cafe where we just we're
gonna get GoPros just 24 hours yeah do
get donations well no okay
the channel would not just be ranked a
fait but I'm saying I would be a lot to
be a program on that channel and
actually get paid the TV programmers out
there and let them broadcast a stream so
we can get more people to join you in
this in the rent cafe calm down recon
cousin that's the next step forward yeah
it's a few steps away another Jake
Paul's gonna come out to like anime and
I will quit yes that what that would
[ __ ] us that would [ __ ] is pretty hard
if there's two things in this world that
I love diving on haters and [ __ ]
anime and I will close my channel not
being an anime youtuber next to this guy
just like a sad song starts playing as
you go to delete your channel no you
make like a [ __ ] fake channel and
then he delete it imperialist opinion
listening they would need to be more on
topic if we were an actual show and I
disagree I disagree all the scripted ass
shows that are on topic man we have
enough of that what we want is the show
where we can just have people like recon
freaking
people like NOx freaking out me
pretending to be the normal guy
meanwhile I'm like stirring it all up
behind the scenes it's beautiful it's
great you're mentioning this cuz
literally right or the rat cafe are we
gonna try to stay on topic
because I don't think we can talk about
one [ __ ] for an hour and adamak says
we never stay on topic everyone likes it
that way yeah yeah man like why why stay
on one specific topic if we can just
chill hang out people in the chat bring
stuff up and then we talk about that why
not that's the whole point is this isn't
like a news you know CNN news program
well then would you make oh that's true
because we tell the truth for the most
part yeah yeah we if we were a CNN news
anyway but we would have nice suits and
pretend like we're serious oh I've never
seen you in this suit Anna Mac yeah do
that one time please do that one who to
the robbery conspiracy suit just do that
one time like you dressed nice and smart
you're ready for Red Cafe ladies and
gentlemen welcome from Red Cafe you know
how hot it would be in a suit man please
don't become another I can
and both samurai likes to dress up in
suits too yeah people tend to you know
be nice in front of camera for the
samurai so it's okay it's too spooky
came in to say can't confirm I'm a
desperate virgin loser so first an
testimony well I don't mean to be mean
or anything but you made a three-hour
video talking about ten one-piece
characters that is special like if he
made a three-hour video there's no way
that he could have a social life is that
way you say well I wouldn't say that
such terrible terms no 2spoopy
is committed bro okay he's committed
he's married to his love of animes so
that's final you'll respect that
mm-hmm what is what is Grammatik saying
you didn't tackle the Ghibli followers
give me photos trying to suggest what
the the quote the anime was a mistake
yeah that's a misquotation I didn't want
to talk about that because it's gonna
clean misquotation
not yes I mean now it's just a mean yes
they're not understanding he's puttin
his point is like what Ana means become
is a mistake because instead of
inspiring like new ideas and new art and
things like that instead people were
just mimicking what's already came out
and what works in it it's become too
formal a ik yeah I mean no matter how
I'm chosen and you know battle shonan's
and yeah meaning he's got to the point
where you know a show comes up you see
the poster you go okay hero rival like
loving trest main villain yeah I mean
and you can roughly predict how the
story's gonna go down you know yeah
another thing that Miyazaki loves to do
is bring out the beauty of life real
life
he likes to bring that out so if you
look at total or anything that's the
whole point of beauty hidden beauty of
real life of everyday life then we need
to appreciate what he doesn't like is
anime that kind of are escapism then
instead of bringing you bringing out the
beauty of real life they're using all
these bright colors and shiny things and
a Sakai settings to basically escape
from the real world instead of embracing
and appreciating the real world so that
I think is another big thing he has with
certain modern anime but of course he
wasn't referring to enemy in particular
he was referring to some of the
critiques he has of aspects of modern
anime which again confirms the fact that
anime is a diverse medium
they're a great anime out there Derek
crap the enemy out there recon god knows
recon those with their crappy anime out
there and how you miss it does not
understand that no no
they are crappy anime up there but it's
not it's not the ones that you guys
think of I know that you I know what you
guys are thinking of but no it's not
crappy I would pay so much money okay to
have Hayao Miyazaki and recon in the
same room reacting to Sao oh [ __ ]
no dream very interesting for me that
would be the best thing I think I could
possibly watch
it's like highschool DxD highschool DxD
live reaction Hayao Miyazaki and a
favorite
well who's hiring me is oh is it the the
director of the anime stop shut down
your channel is it the director of the
anime that has the big cat what the Hana
mainly because you talking about
you do Ghibli recon for big white cat I
would say I would say totoro's not a cat
there's a cat bus in total yeah yeah
there's the bus Toto is not a cat so no
no no yo okay I'm kind of stunned recon
I'm kind of stunned well I'm a little
more stunned because Ana Mack mother's
basement just posted he's not sure which
anime is better hero academia or
re-creators why would you compare those
two they're completely different what I
think I don't know about anime the
season
but I would say the hero academia has
kept my interest more sold than me
creators like we can't finish now and
I'm still on my episode 40 recreate used
to say that my hero academia actually
kept your interest whereas recreator did
not and I told him I'm working on a
sarcastic trailer and he said he's
looking forward to it I have to I have
to say that the three creator students
started off interesting but I did lose
interest and I haven't kept up I'm
almost like episode working yeah yeah
same here I think I'm on Episode four
didn't grip me in a way that I think a
lot of it a lot of it is the fact that
the main male guy like the team dude
whose name I don't know is completely
soldier yeah yeah point less nothing to
relate to him no personality
so even though like some of the other
characters are okay it doesn't really
draw me it's not even that it's it's the
case of it feels like he doesn't even
have a role in the show like I mean we
know that okay yeah he's connected to
the creator of auteur yeah okay but
other than that he has no presence in
the show when fights are happening he
ain't doing nothing because he's not the
main focus people wouldn't focus on him
yeah I know but he's the main character
was the point inside line in your main
character he's not really a main
character yeah that the problem with him
is is that he's nothing special he's
he's a unnecessary like if you didn't
have him in the show the show would be
the same like there would be nothing but
saying why are we watching from his
perspective like what's the [ __ ]
point I mean for me I watched it all I
like I like the way it ended and I hope
it gets a season two so yeah I know we
have some people arguing in there about
my hero academia mm-hmm whether it's too
simplistic or whether it's good the
thing is
so my making my name aside or I'm making
a five fatal flaws video on my hair
academia plug your videos after I'm done
my speech but your speeches sometimes go
forever I know there's the whole points
of rants Cafe well but Rancho Bay we
should all get like at least five
minutes of talking in here
never never like once we're loggin comes
up to finish up my father and then you
can talk spray your fresh interrupt
um the with my hair I agree that certain
arcs are not as compelling to me as
others so for example I really like the
stained arc and I thought that the after
the stain cells
yes like so the stain stuff interesting
build up with stuff and then after this
taste of the the exam mark was much less
interesting so that to me kind of sucks
that they're finishing off the season on
a less interesting note and it was more
interesting in the middle this season
however reading the manga if you don't
you read the manga the next two arcs are
freakin insane so the next time my
friends are gonna be like like way
crazier than anything we've seen so far
so if you thought the the end of first
season the us junior was crazy this is
crazy
earth so against Lee I have a bunch of
issues with the usj arc as well well it
was more interesting than the to me than
the urgent stuff but the point is with
my your theme it's not a perfect show
there is like I said certain arcs that
are better than others also i Waldeck
who is getting better now if you read
the manga and again the manga is what
really convinced me to stay with the
show if you read the manga Beck who is
getting better but at first he's too
much for a crybaby and I didn't like
that
however there are other characters that
I really like like so totally dokey
they're like like I have to watch the
show because of them because they are
compelling characters to meet and
staying as well very interesting
character so yeah that kind of stuff
kept me going with the show also a lot
of people died MacNeil yoki oh by the
way I haven't seen it yet
but I know a lot of people are going
crazy over it so I don't know I have to
knocks talk about your Baron Baron did a
video on it already
Baron Trump not bad Baron Baron J
youtuber I'm like I mean I did like the
fighting where all the characters took
the exams especially the fight were the
deku deku and bak ago versus all mine I
did enjoy it but it was too short and
that was your problem with it
no points it did bore me I mean I felt
the fight was too short it wasn't too
intense I mean I know deku landed like a
putt like a power puncher at all mine
but then he just escaped he let them go
and like won come on so yeah I was a
little bit disappointed with that but um
honestly what can all Mike when he
punches and a typhoon you know starts
billowing behind him and blows everyone
away frankly if he needs back you go in
the face and he goes flying into the
third storey of the building and blows
up the building because of the impact
I don't know how honestly he just gets
up and starts shooting more explosions
at him it's it's things like that that
are throughout the series that are just
like come on make sense like Jojo bleach
Naruto all these friendship invincible
and Naruto is Naruto Naruto is way more
tightly knit in that power aspect and
how strong every attack is than my hero
academia because Dec ooze flick I I've
said this before but his finger the part
of his finger that catches the air is
less than an inch or
dimitr I don't know it's not huge and it
causes winds that are way stronger than
a typhoon okay how fast does his finger
need to be going well according to math
it needs to be going a lot faster than
light okay and you could run as fast as
you can flick according to the powers of
the Internet and therefore you're
talking out a guy who can move the speed
of light so if he punches staying in the
face with even 5% of his power that
punch is moving at fifty-four million
miles an hour at least you realize do
you realize stain just gets up he didn't
even get affected by it like the first
six times he got punched in the face or
Todoroki in the stomach but bro but bro
this ain't a factual show you do you
understand that but bro it has to make
sense a little not a factual show like
feel you know connected to a show where
facts don't exist okay so you not
connected with dojo with deals head
[ __ ] surviving without buddy then
buddy he was a vampire who he's heads to
our if you want got powers they have to
follow the rules that you give them not
say good games both so Jaden is like can
you guys not all talk at the same same
time yeah good luck with that man I
don't think I'm gonna happen especially
with recon and NOx in the same carnival
a quick question since we're out of
topic can we talk about si oh no no but
we can talk about JoJo's which handle
most tightly-knit channels is the reason
why not
kickboxer hates anime yeah I think
there's no waifu's and JoJo's unless you
count like wonder why there's no wife
who's in Jojo Jojo
I already told you my for Sena ran amok
you already know there's no point
debating with someone who doesn't know
because just like the kickboxer who
knows nothing about anime and fights to
bash it
that's pretty much what you're doing
about JoJo's you have no idea what
you're talking about and you think you
do well I'm not really a [ __ ] I'm not
really a bad thing but I am kind of like
sympathetic skeptical who Souls Souls
critics well we lost you again yeah
knock stop muting soul yeah well yeah I
think that there is in terms of anime
like I said it's the beautiful thing
about it is that it is so diverse so we
can talk about Shonen we can talk about
serious anime with serious topics like
Psychopaths Ergo Proxy we can talk about
just itchy harem stuff usually most
let's talk about it as just like hot I
was funnier and you know it was so bad
it was good recon not so much but you
know that's the beauty of it the
diversity of the fandom and of anime as
a genre and just like I mean you have in
Western media you have more serious
films you have comedy films your action
films you have films dear towards
children but that adults can still enjoy
like I don't know Disney films so I mean
it's just as diverse as that but people
have this stigma or like this
misconception that all of anime is this
certain thing that I don't like where I
think it's stupid and then I kind of
project that onto others but I think
very soon people are gonna start looking
stupid when that happens because anime
is becoming more mainstream and the more
mainstream it becomes the more people
learn about it and yeah so I think
that's that's was gonna end up happening
however I do want to say Nux you were
gonna plug your videos and then didn't
but I was gonna say on your most recent
video when he talked about Hanukkah
which was your yo NOx video right yeah
you said that
Oh chuckle Veronica is not a good female
character no I can't disagree with
anything you say however I maintain that
she is designed in a way
in a lab scientists psychologists design
her in a way to make her so cute that
you cannot possibly dislike her even if
she had no character personalities
whatsoever
I can't dislike her because the way
she's drawn it's like it's just like
kawaii off-the-charts like I you can't
the cycle like she smiles you just like
if she would have been inkay on she
would have been best girl because she
did about as much as anyone in k-on did
in this year's hmm he is kind of like a
K on type character in visually but in
my world are you saying that like her
fight against back you go didn't happen
or something well she lost what so you
didn't actually accomplish anything or
succeed in anything she only she even
beat hero 21 he 11 whatever whoever was
that person that's not a boy or a girl
apparently um weird as that is but um
first of all she won because of a Yama
who is pretty much one of the greatest
characters in fiction okay this is why
because you're insane and I'm also
sarcastic but um and Erica what was hero
11 trying to do in that fight space hero
13 13 whatever who cares I don't even
know the characters names well 13 relax
Miyazaki please the cat guy right so
what was 13's game plan in that fight
basically I don't I think the plan was
to scare them and keep
from escaping but I'll actually kill me
a break there was nothing that 13 I'm
not gonna say he or she because you know
and that 13th actually looking for 13
was looking to suck him into a black
hole and it and capture them sucking
into a black hole doesn't compress your
body it but it's in the bottom line
sucking you Taraka into hair into it and
beat him that was it that was all fight
the old fight was he sucks it using it
sucks that using it's quick okay because
don't show this video to Pedro anyway 13
is it's not weird the 13 doesn't have a
gender because if you look at that world
people have crazy ass quirks some people
are at are snakes and [ __ ] so it could
be the 13 was just born without a
physical gender because as a result of
the quirk that created like he could
have bone invisible yeah I don't think
13 decided that I'm not gonna I don't
want to I don't want to be called a man
or a woman because I don't want to I
think that it's a thing where as a
result of the quark 13 does not
necessarily have a conventional gender
the way we think of it because quirks
cause obviously huge drastic mutations
in that world so that's kind of mind if
it's just hard to talk about the person
I'm not saying that it doesn't make
sense
oh yes I guess but the thing in with
with that battle I think it's it was
just like 13 was trying to use the
powerful quark to keep them from
escaping but then because Veronica
suddenly fell off 30 new the Karaka
would be killed
so 13 turned off the quark and that's it
and then they were able to so basically
they shocked 13 into kind of like into
make a mistake 13 that quark is not good
for the type of test they put it in that
quark is just deadly like you know so
it's like that quark was useless yeah
cuz the Sony deadly obviously he's not
okay well no okay then that's the point
no but there's nothing that thirteen
could have actually done it was a stupid
exam yeah I will agree with that I don't
think that the thirteenth quirk is well
suited for an exam at all like I'm
saying that's not considered an
accomplishment and naraka sparked that
she got embarrassed and just flew into
the guy no it's not an accomplishment
but the thing I want to say is Grammatik
mentioned that you can't hate the
minions because they are designed to be
so cute and silly and I think that that
is like the first thing when I see what
Eric I think of the minions it's like
these people were genetically engineered
or like whatever creatively engineered
to make you like them by their physical
appearance no matter what their persona
is because they're just so kawaii it's
just messed up it's just messed up oh
wait so I'll just want to confirm so she
has to have feats I guess do you do you
like or willing to accept what you
didn't catch that you know like feats of
like the feat in people and whatever no
but there was no feat in anything there
was no character development there was
no actual accomplishments there is no
reason why I should like her aside from
the fact that she's a minion but there
is character the vote yeah she was
someone who wants to become a hero to
make money and she said yeah and
characters I prefer I prefer zero he
also developed emotionally understanding
now that she has feelings for decade do
our earphone jack yeah I like I like
Momo the best probably ensue you out of
this yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't see
how gyros better than record oh wow I
don't know what the moment
you've seen because she's development
development wise the support cast didn't
develop at all in my here academia which
includes Giro and it includes basically
almost everyone and it slowly work the
problem is they have twenty students in
the one class of course so obviously
we're not gonna understand the backstory
of sugar boy who like the worst thing
ever so but aside from that I don't
blame them for not developing a support
character but a main character should at
least have some development a little
she's not she's not a main character
though Baraka yes she is sure she is the
main female character yes Josh dusty be
a main character
Josh she's the main female know she is
what is Josh she's made of eight weeks
old
stop guys stop okay stop talking over
each other and arguing Josh Duffy said
hatsune MA and more best girls and I
will agree with that hot some ma is very
cool cool female character but again we
don't like not you right girl stop we
need more development like you said for
spectators I agree
but on the other hand it's hard to
develop so many characters because it's
a world with many characters okay so
yeah it sounds like you can go it's a go
I personally would love to see more
development for certain characters like
that then focus on baku go and deku deku
who just like their rivalry like who
cares to me because it's like such a
cliche vegeta goku ash gary you know you
name it rivalry it's not me it brings
nothing unique to it whereas some of
these other characters with interesting
quirks bring unique things to it
well toga toga is is is better there is
a villain yonder II though that's coming
on the season we're talking about I
don't know her name so why do we invite
this guy I don't even
oh he's even late to anime he don't even
know Miyazaki's [ __ ] I know who Miyazaki
is but I don't know the name of the
yandere girl what's her name again
gimmick vulgar toga okay I hope I'll
remember that I hope you will too yeah
I'm sure you won't want to yeah yeah
like I said I'm really I have high
expectations of season three I think
it's gonna be crazy I hope we get
announcement soon like we did for icon
Titan
we got the announcement for season three
at the end of yeah we'll Holly straight
away I'm really hoping that we get the
season 3 announcement for my hero
academia at the end of the season finale
which is this Saturday right
that'll be crazy and I'll also be dinner
with a dock on Titan especially because
the tackling time was like oh my god are
gonna wait another four years so that
was really cool by the way also overlord
season 2 is coming in the winter and
one-punch France season 2 is in danger
of not even being [ __ ] made because
they're switching Studios and show
producers and everything never a good
sign guys don't dump your news video on
the rant cafe just cuz you ditched it
[Laughter]
hey Knox when is your flight part series
on whatever you're doing coming out well
I didn't even announce it officially and
I didn't commit to it so you never know
Knox where's your alo si oh I never
commit to that either I just made a
thumbnail and sent it to you to be funny
you need to do it I don't know about
that well I love how you don't commit to
[ __ ] but you like to call me out for no
[ __ ] well you do commit and you fail
hence the problem if you don't commit I
have no issue hey well if you don't try
you'll never know and if you do although
I did commit to borrow to episode 2 and
it's been like three months yes where's
that where's bore times a to [ __ ] good
point
look I admit my own fault here but in
case you didn't realize it takes like
three months to edit it as and gather
over 20 voice actors including you and
stuff like that whereas the news video
yeah I accept if you do the news video
every week and spend five hours doing it
every single week it adds up buddy maybe
like maybe you're just I never actually
gave a date we're bored so episode two
is coming out exactly cuz your weak man
well you mean I win because uh I don't
just fail and disappoint everyone this
call for anime versus nooks yeah well
that that will be a fun showdown because
I will destroy him and have him binge
watch JoJo's and eat ice cream after
he's depressed I'm never gonna watch my
dream anyway whatever your next knocks
whatever your next abridging is you
better make me the villain and I'm gonna
be writing my own lines and crushing you
yeah that's gonna happen I'm sorry but
the villain misty and he's such a great
done ok boruto but you said you're gonna
do other abridgement so come on
I'm currently working with three editors
you have any idea how hard it is to edit
yourself mad well then I have to give up
on things I commit to anyways I won't do
this conversation isn't going anywhere
just admit that I'm right let's admit
that anime is awesome and that people
shouldn't get so triggered when people
in other people consult Amy because it's
just ignorance right so it's like if you
know if you're confident in yourself in
anime as a genre even though obviously
has stupid stuff you have to believe in
the you that believes in anime exactly
and of course there's also certain
aspects of the anime fandom some people
that are just ridiculous and act in a
ridiculous ways you know if you go to
cons you see some people just kind of
make it a mockery of things but that
doesn't mean that that's a
representation of anime as a whole so I
think people should just be more
confident about animes or honor above
themselves and not get into this whole
like give and go with trolls who
basically want a reaction this guy
wanted a reaction that's why he made
such a blatantly you know inflammatory
tweet and a lot of people took debate
and I know it's like drama cells and
it's cool I don't mind talking about it
I don't mind you know discussing it with
you guys but don't let it actually cuz I
don't get it let it get to me I just
have
and I think it's interesting to talk
about and to joke about but don't
actually let it get you and get
triggered as they say if someone insults
anime because usually they do it out of
ignorance and you know I'm here for that
of ignorance to Sao can be insulted
based on its qualities when saying all
the way I'll pick some I'll fix their
talk well he's gonna love my video is a
video no knucks is doing me the favor is
yo he's finally doing Sao videos I wish
we could get have like a con panel like
a convention panel where knock sorry
cannot could go face to face live debate
holds barred no one say come on guys one
at a time just like just go at it see
what I've already gonna fight are they
gonna move I think I actually like end
up fighting are they gonna end up
hugging like we don't know we don't know
but it would be an amazing thing to
watch well about what what are we gonna
be arguing about Sao anything I don't
care I can't argue about it I know you
can look you don't have any points to
your side to argue if you just say it's
good cuz I like it cuz it's good and you
just give me some points on why it's bad
and I'll just rephrase what you said in
a good way okay cuz no character no
character no Kenzi how's that
what no characters had development so
many characters have development okay so
that's where a debate will end yeah
Kirito have development also net
development the the other girls didn't
really have development yeah you're kind
of right about that but other characters
did have to about she can't say no
everyone had development well I don't
want to get it to an essay oh thing now
really yeah let's not get into it there
is some development but the question is
whether it's enough whether it's good
and there's definitely even recon
understands that a lot of the girls
introduced we're just like side harem
tokens which is stupid but
yes we'll get into this another time I
just want to say like I said again guys
don't get triggered by people gain on
anime anime is the future they can't
stop us bro
they can't stop us all so let's face it
none of us would say that anything to
this guy to his face because he's a
[ __ ] champion world change whoever
does proves his point exactly yeah like
we're all talking [ __ ] off you [ __ ] [ __ ]
online but I'm sure not also come up to
be like your anime is good man fight me
it's not me Casta for life meet ten baby
that's how we do it I think this is a
good time to wrap it up everybody you
can join the conversation on our discord
if you want to talk on a day-to-day
basis obviously we do write to say every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
leave a like if you like rank of a link
in description for this chord recon who
are you what do you do can I go what are
some poor boys this your boy recon a k
recon no Picou the harem King you know
what I'm talking about the SAO lover why
does he do this guy's I don't know
because keep going keep going yeah I
finish yeah okay let your channel what
are you doing you're chill I do them I
do them top tens
okay next that's it that's it top 10
what top 10 anime I think we should talk
for him hi this is recon he actually
makes your music and stuff yeah talks
about the last one and its quality and
its substantive himself yeah its quality
quality editing quality craftsmanship
thank you recon you were great knocks
the offer continuing for me
knocks Taku what's up it's your boy next
Taku here a buddy of recons in anime and
we're good friends we never get into
arguments or anything and on my channel
I do very
it's like okay slightly opinionated
videos and analysis sarcastic stuff
basically whatever I'm in the mood to do
just because my channel is not too big
enough to actually find a place to put
myself in any case on to you so okay hi
yeah
hello everyone so maca I have just
started my channel at the moment I've
got a video for a anime - manga
comparison for Korra no katachi I will
be doing others in the future I will
also be doing an introduction to anime -
manga sorry introduction to manga videos
and different manga reviews on our
series that are complete I also draw
hentai as well and I'm working on a
visual novel game nice so send me the
link to your channel and I will put it
yeah I'll put it in the yeah yeah okay
cool
sounds good alright thank you guys again
for joining me and having our fun chat
it's never frustrating and always fun
alright guys thank you into chat for
being here with us and witnessing the
greatness that is recon versus Knox vs
and a Mac with soul maka just chilling
this time he wasn't in the as usual
sometimes he gets triggered like when he
clearly has to admit defeat to me about
Cowboy Bebop Amelia stop it uh but
anyways yeah stop we understand your
tactic in winning fights by now anime
basically saying okay you have good
points but you lose yes yes and because
I'm the host I can do that it's
beautiful and that's right no one
complains and we bow tear immeasurable
power yes excellent now you understand
it well you can still not defeat it oh
yeah thanks guys for coming out as
always always a fun time one day we'll
make this rant this Red Cafe panel
happen where NOx and recon are actually
going to end up hospitalizing each other
can't wait after a eight hour debate and
it'll show down it's gonna be beautiful
but until next time which is next week
see a space cowboys